[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
locales et régionales et sur tv5 monde
avec la participation de la presse
quotidienne régionale
voici les titres de cette édition du coc
vide dans les eaux usées la ville de
limoges a lancé une opération quartier
par quartier pour voir où le virus
circule le plus nous avons suivi cette
investigation surprenante avec 7 à
limoges escape game même le coc vide la
crise du corridor a permis de fabriquer
de nouveaux jeux qui sensibilise à la
vaccination
comme cette escape game ludique que nous
fait découvrir dans un instant tv7 la
chaîne du groupe sud ouest disparus puis
revenu il avait totalement disparu de
nos massifs au début du 20e siècle
le gypaète barbu repeuplent désormais
les massifs de la haute savoie
nous partirons avec 8 mont blanc à la
découverte de cet oiseau des zones de
montagne
enfin connaissez-vous le fath bike un
vélo originale à grosses roues il est
électrique et vous permet de découvrir
la montagne tout en pédalant dans la
neige on commence ce journal en nous
rendant dans le limousin où pour la
première fois l'analyse des eaux usées a
permis de lancer une action ciblée dans
la traque de lakovic 19 avec à la clé
des analyses beaucoup plus précises dans
chaque quartier de limoges pour voir où
le virus circule
un reportage de benjamin delmas de cet
aliment est sur place
pour la première fois l'analyse des eaux
usées a permis de lancer une action
ciblée à limoges leur analyse a montré
une possible montée de l'épidémie de
kobe 19 ces derniers jours dans une
partie du quartier du val de l'aurence
si l'eau usée et analysés depuis mai
dernier pour traquer le virus le
dispositif est monté en régime en ce
début d'année avec deux nouveaux points
d'analystes dans les différents
collecteurs ont fait du coup deux
prélèvements par semaine c'est la
moyenne un quartier absolument par
quartier bien ciblés au niveau des ehpad
des eaux plutôt à la clé des analyses
beaucoup plus précises dans chaque
quartier pour voir où le virus circule
le plus comme ce fut le cas dans le
quartier du val de l'aurence le virus en
fait est excrété par les personnes dans
les selles seyssel vont dans les eaux
usées et c'est ce virus là dont on va
retrouver le génome au niveau des eaux
usées dans le secteur de jean le bail
des tests ont donc été menée ce mercredi
pour les habitants de cette zone
habituellement on fait des opérations de
dépistage et on regarde si on retrouve
le virus dans les eaux usées là on est
parti à l'envers c'est à dire qu'on
surveille les eaux usées et on a eu un
hotspot donc un taux de virus importants
dont les eaux usées du quartier jean le
bail et donc nous avons décidé
conjointement avec la mairie de lancer
une action de dépistage et on a eu le
soutien de la rs pour faire cette action
dépistage toujours sur le front du coc
vide depuis janvier la résidence de la
champagne à troyes attend de pouvoir
vacciner ses locataires
il y a quelques semaines déjà la
direction se préparait à vacciner les
résidents volontaires avec un protocole
adéquat mais en raison de
l'impossibilité d'avoir des doses les
rendez vous n'ont pas été honorées les
résidents s'impatiente et l' agence
régionale de santé a contacté
l'établissement afin de relancer la
vaccination des personnes prioritaires
l'établissement troyen peut désormais
planifier la vaccination à partir du 1er
mars prochain
un reportage de canal 32 sur place
regardez depuis les premières
vaccinations dans l'aube le 7 janvier
les résidents prioritaires de cet
établissement attendent avec impatience
leur tour sont cuisinés visible pour
être comme tous les autres en france est
prioritaire nous sommes tous âgés dans
le style on our head vacciner si on
tombe malade tous les genres ici on va
embêter tous les hôpitaux
il y aura plus de place pour les autres
alors qu'on nous vaccine comme chômeurs
la paix on est tous inquiet pour je suis
inquiète pour eux les familles
on est tous inquiets pour eux c'est
important de le faire le plus vite
possible parce que justement ça les
protège au départ on était prêt à
prendre des rendez vous sur d'autolib
pour les résidents trouver un moyen de
transport les emmener mais en fin de
compte ya pas de rendez-vous disponible
non plus ici la direction est d'ores et
déjà prête à organiser sur place selon
ce protocole une séance de vaccination
nous après ce feu vert arrive en fin de
matinée via un e-mail de l'agencé
régionale de santé
vous allez pouvoir programmer
l'organisation de la vaccination au sein
de votre structure
à compter du 1er mars 2021 dès janvier
la rsa signaler d'éventuels retards en
raison du manque de doses dans les ehpad
résidence ou à domicile les personnes
âgées restent comme prévu prioritaire
vous savez on a été contraint de
reporter un petit peu la campagne de
vaccination de l'oms
maintenant on la reprend évidemment les
premières doses accessibles seront pour
les ré les résidents des résidences
autonomie ici la vaccination à venir ne
changera pas le quotidien activités en
distance yale et absence de repas en
commun resteront leurs règles ça
changera surtout pas les gestes barrière
a aujourd'hui on a géré une organisation
très stricte
ça donnera plus de confort moral à nos
résidents et leur contact avec leurs
familles sur les 57 résidents de cet
établissement 45 ans d'exprimer leur
souhait d'être vacciné qu'ovide toujours
depuis la mi-décembre l'école de rugby
de lumio à 10km de calvi en corse a pu
reprendre le chemin de l'entraînement
dans le respect des gestes-barrières
bien sûr les jeunes rugbymen corse sont
parfaitement adaptés aux nouvelles
contraintes
grâce au travail des bénévoles du club
qui ont adapté les exercices afin de
rassurer les parents les éducateurs
permettent aux jeunes de se défouler sur
le terrain écoutez l'interview de la
vice présidente du club des membres de
la ligue de rugby corse d'ailleurs et de
là
commission féminine non ce qu'on a mis
en place est en fait le protocole qui
est proposé par la ligue de rugby c'est
à dire c'est le protocole reprises dans
les écoles de rugby de stade iii c'est à
dire qu'on permet aux jeunes de
s'entraîner de courir de se dépenser
tout en respectant les règles sanitaires
en vigueur au lieu d'être un sport de
contact on est devenu un sport
d'évitement
voilà et on retourne en nouvelles
aquitaine avec ces images si on
assistait à des concerts en live stream
l'association qui dit quoi basée à
limoges propose aux artistes musicaux de
remonter sur scène pour des captures
vidéo à retrouver en live et en direct
depuis son canapé comme vous pouvez le
voir et on part en bretagne maintenant
pour une bonne idée apprendre le métier
de commerçant en trois mois
l'idée du dispositif la boutique école
c'est une initiative portée par une
association dont la vocation est
d'accompagner les porteurs de projets en
fait il s'agit d'une boutique écoles
entre magasins et formation et elle
s'est implantée dans un quartier de
lorient depuis plusieurs semaines
rencontre avec ces apprentis commerçants
reportage de karine chevrollier pour
tébéo la chaîne du groupe le télégramme
trois mois pour devenir commerçant c'est
le défi proposé par la boutique école à
lorient l'idée c'est d'être dans une
boutique tests avec des vraies marges
une vraie caisse vambre pu voir si ça
fonctionne et en fonction de ça adapter
les choses qui ne vont pas s'il ya des
produits qui se vendent mieux que
d'autres va peut-être moins investir sur
ce qui se vend pour que le jour où ils
devront passer dans leur vrai commerce
le plus de chance possible de réussir
mais tenir une boutique cela ne
s'improvise pas avant d'investir les
lieux
les quatre graines de commerçants sont
passés par une formation pour
appréhender les bases on a appris
beaucoup de choses marchandising
chalandise où se positionner selon nos
produits et tout ce qui est les eps
d'avoir micro-entreprises entreprise je
suis né en russie donc les lois ne sont
pas par et les règles ne sont pas paraît
donc ça fait du bien de tours aux voix
puissantes a pitié on avance et puis on
ouvre sa boutique une opportunité donnée
à quatre porteurs de projets tous issus
de cursus différents et pas forcément en
lien avec le commerce
chacun a son propre univers de vente
mais travailler ensemble
permet de gagner en confiance on a tous
eu tout à apprendre
donc je me retrouvais dans le même au
même niveau que tout le monde à 0
j'avais besoin de ça en fait me remettre
à niveau pouvoir avoir la capacité de me
reconcentrer c'est simple difficile pour
moi reste à chacun de prendre son envol
la prochaine formation est déjà en
préparation en tout seize personnes vont
bénéficier de ce dispositif sur l'année
voilà un escape game je vous le disais
dans les titres pour sensibiliser à la
vaccination
c'est le dernier projet piloté et
financé par l' agence régionale de santé
à destination du personnel des ehpad en
gironde
objectif informer de façon ludique sur
le vaccin contre la copie de 19 et ainsi
réduire l'hésitation comptes-tu certains
parfois à se faire vacciner
immersion au coeur du jeu de la start up
triki à l'ehpad de château garde hier de
talence c'est bénédicte dohin pour tv7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest qui s'y
est rendue pour d'eau qu'est-ce que vous
avez d'autres informations de sud ou sur
ces trois ans est plongé dans cet
univers futuriste les quatre employés
tentent de percer le mystère des
logiciels antivirus une thématique plus
que jamais d'actualité mais que le béa
et c3 c'est en rapport avec ce qu'on vit
le coc vide
donc c'est bien ça me permet de voir un
peu à la complexité d'une tâche très mal
fabriqués avec son infirmière cuisinier
ou encore lingère les 70 employés de
l'établissement sont concernés par
l'opération des employés pour qui la
vaccination n'est pas toujours une
évidence les professionnels de santé et
aux trains aussi voilà on a des
cuisiniers on a des administratifs qui
se pose tout un tas de questions qui ont
des appréhensions sur les effets à court
et à long terme de la vaccination alors
c'était déjà pour la grippe eu d'autres
vaccins et puis là avec l'aco vide
actuellement on a remarqué à nouveau
sept
cette crainte est donc on a souhaité un
petit peu travaillé là dessus et les
leur faire prendre conscience de la
nécessité de trier des informations une
fois la partie terminée un débriefing
s'impose avec un médiateur de santé un
temps de parole et d'écouté où chacun
aborde ses sentiments quant à la
vaccination
il ya entre 45 minutes et 60 minutes
d'exposition dans la phase iib merci et
45 minutes sous 60 minutes sur la face
de débriefing parce que c'est bien
l'enjeu de pouvoir libérer la parole et
que chaque participant et le temps de
bien réfléchir de pouvoir exposer les
problématiques qu'il vit au quotidien
au total six établissements girondins
font partie du programme d'ici la fin du
mois 400 employés auront participé à
cette escale game voilà regardez ce
reportage il peut vous êtes très utile
maintenant car quand vous composer un
numéro d'urgence comme celui des
pompiers ou des gendarmes tout un
processus se mettent en place pour que
votre appel s'adresse à la bonne urgence
l'occasion dans la loire vous allez le
voir de se rendre compte de comment les
appels sont réceptionnés et traiter les
pompiers et la gendarmerie nationale du
département nous ont ouvert leurs portes
un sujet d'adrien bletterie et d'alice
kaniv pour la télévision de la loire tl7
c'est ici que les appels d'urgence sont
réceptionnés chaque jour par les sapeurs
pompiers de la loire
en tout sur l'année ce sont 20 % des 300
mille appels qui proviennent du 112 le
centre s'appuie sur un grand open space
avec une technologie moderne et repensé
pour chaque opérateur ont des postes
informatiques avec de la cartographie
avec
des grilles spécifique d' alerte qui
nous permette d'engager nos moyens et en
os pour l'ensemble des opérateurs pour
l'ensemble des personnes qui se trouvent
dans le centre de traitement de la verte
des informations à l'affichage la carte
du département avec toutes les
interventions qui s'affiche le 112 peut
être composés à partir d'un téléphone
fixe ou portable sans crédit et avec
n'importe quel opérateur européen
il vous permet de joindre les sapeurs
pompiers le samu et la police
on a en interconnexion avec les autres
services donc le samu la police la
gendarmerie et on pourra se mettre en
conférence à propos justement du côté de
la police nationale l'année 2020 si
particulière a provoqué une augmentation
des appels du 112 c'est vrai que durant
2020 on est passé à plus 40 appels jour
en moyenne
donc les chiffres ont été augmentées par
l'effet de la crise sanitaire
trois quarts des appels sont des
demandes de renseignements mais depuis
la crise sanitaire
la police nationale constate une
augmentation des violences physiques
dans les familles qu'elles soient
confinés ou non un couvre-feu à 18
heures est très contraignant malgré ce
qu'on peut penser parce que les gens qui
travaillent
son travail jusqu'à 18 heures à 18
heures faut qu'ils rentrent chez eux et
donc ils seront on va dire un peu
confiné donc sans compter ceux qui
télétravaillent qui ne sort plus et tous
les appels provenant d'un téléphone
portable et géolocalisés par la police
nationale
bonjour michel picaud c'est le moment
dans la rubrique écorégions dans le
grand jt des territoires avec toujours
ces entreprises madeinfrance que vous
nous présentez alors de quoi s'agit-il
cette semaine
bonjour cyril bonjour à vous tous la
crise sanitaire nous contraint bien
souvent rester à la maison pour
télétravailler mais beaucoup se heurte à
un problème de taille notamment dans un
appartement en ville
si le manque de lumière naturelle nous
travaillons bien souvent avec des lampes
de bureau fait de mieux et pourtant il
existe une solution a été mise au point
à lille elle s'appelle et spatiales le
principe est tout simple
installé à sa fenêtre ou balcon un
réflecteur de lumière naturelle
une sorte de miroir qui va réfléchir la
lumière naturelle pour la projeter final
on à l'intérieur de votre logement et le
succès a été au rendez vous bien avant
la crise sanitaire d'ailleurs il faut
savoir qu'en france une maison sur cinq
est exposée au nord donc assez loin de
la lumière du jour
aujourd'hui la start-up lance un nouveau
panneau réflecteurs intelligent car il
va suivre la courbe du soleil tout au
long de la journée
une manière originale de laisser entrer
le soleil dans sa maison et surtout de
se faire du bien
le soleil est d'une importance
fondamentale pour la santé pour le
rythme biologique le cycle du sommeil la
synthèse de la vitamine d ou encore la
sécrétion de sérotonine
voilà j'ose le dire une idée lumineuse
médine lille qui non seulement on peut
vous faire du bien mais qui permet aussi
d'économiser de l'électricité
merci michel picaud au rendez vous dans
une prochaine édition du grand jt des
territoires voilà je vous le disais dans
les titres l'oiseau le gypaète barbu
avait totalement disparu de nos massifs
au début du 20e siècle mais avec la mise
en place d'un plan de réintroduction
dans les années 90 l'espèce est de
retour dans son environnement naturel en
haute savoie c'est le conservatoire des
espaces naturels qui est en charge de
leur suivi un organisme qui a d'ailleurs
enregistré plusieurs pontes dans le
centre d'élevage cette année une
première une explication avec ce
reportage d'emmanuel jo pour 8 mont
blanc regarder
depuis 25 ans déjà les gypaètes barbus
réinvestissent peu à peu les alpes
cela grâce à un projet de réintroduction
européen qui a d'ores et déjà permis à
une cinquantaine de couples de
s'installer dans leur calepin et parmi
les premiers sites à avoir séduit un de
ces couples la falaise du bar j sur les
hauteurs du reposoir un lieu toujours
surveillées aujourd'hui afin de
comprendre et suivre l'évolution de
cette population
pour garantir une gestion optimale de
l'animal l'observation n'est pas le seul
outil du conservatoire des espaces
naturels de haute savoie
depuis les années 85 si je dis pas de
bêtises
aster gère aussi un instant d'élevage
avec des oiseaux des gypaètes en
captivité et l'objectif c'est qu'ils se
reproduisent et du coup de relâcher ses
poussins que ce soit pendant longtemps
en haute savoie mais on participe aussi
aux efforts de lâcher dans toutes les
alpes également d'un massif central en
espagne encore soit là puisque
l'objectif c'est de recoloniser tout l
on va dire le pourtour méditerranéen si
aujourd'hui en france 18 couples sont
connus et suivi ce nombre pourrait bien
augmenter avec la ponte de trois
femelles du centre d'élevage cette année
pourtant la prudence reste de mise
l'hiver étant une période critique pour
l'espèce synonyme d'accouplement et
rendant donc les rapaces plus sensibles
à leur environnement
c'est une espèce très sensible déjà qui
se reproduit très lentement c'est à dire
que les oiseaux ils sont adultes que
vers 7 ou 8 ans ne se reproduise pas
avant et en moyenne ils produisent un
poussin parcours tous les trois ans donc
si en plus on rajoute nos perturbations
humaines lit un passage d'hélico qui va
effrayer l'oiseau qui va s'envoler
on conseille de sensibiliser tous ces
acteurs en fonction des sites puisque
différents sites vont pas avoir les
mêmes types de perturbations une
communication essentielle qui permet
d'années en années de pouvoir faire
croître la population des gypaètes dans
nos massifs comme dans tout l'arc alpin
voilà en regardant ce journal vous êtes
peut-être près d'un repas donc ce sujet
va vous intéresser
il s'agit de la création d'une nouvelle
spécialité gastronomique et lé sarthoise
car bientôt ce département pourra se
vanter d'avoir une nouvelle spécialité
culinaire c'est en tout cas le projet de
gwenaëlle l'huissier l'éleveur de la
poule le mans une raçon % sarthoise a
rassemblé autour de cette ambition des
producteurs des restaurateurs et des
apprentis cuisine
nier du département ils se sont
rencontrés pour la première fois à début
février au lycée hôtelier funés hélène
boucher et margot bien qu pour vyas lmtv
sarthe
il était bien sûr pour nous au menu de
cette création gastronomique des
produits du terroir sont imposés le
sarrasin le cresson le vin jasnières
mais aussi la volaille du mans et les
rillettes
on a une potée un peu populaire qu'on
retrouve dans différentes régions de
france
là l'idée c'était de mettre vraiment en
place un plat d'un bon niveau
gastronomique qui représente tout
simplement l'histoire de notre
département de nos beaux produits
justement et celle des chefs qui
s'évertue à faire les choses le mieux
possible
huit chefs restaurateurs prennent place
à la table du projet de gwenaëlle lui
sied aux côtés de deux vignerons et d'un
spécialiste des rillettes un encadrement
rêvée pour les apprentis cuisiniers des
lycées sainte catherine et hélène
boucher impliqués dans cette brigade
exceptionnel c'est enrichissant et de se
dire que l'on pourra inscrire à un plat
typique dans le de la région c
comme quelque chose d'assez spécial si
la phase de réflexion autour d'une
spécialité gastronomique sarthoise ne
fait que commencer
les chefs ont déjà des idées plein la
tête quand même département
beaucoup d'éleveurs et maraîchers donc
voilà le mettre en avant que c'est bien
quoi je crois que ça fait très longtemps
que j'ai pas vu autant de chefs dans un
même endroit à part la vente de
remporter en ce moment on n'a pas
beaucoup de contacts donc cette soirée
là je pense qu'elle va rester un petit
peu grave et pour l'instant et puis on
va faire que améliorer le projet à
partir de ce soir
l'élaboration de la future spécialité
sarthoise devrait être prête pour le
printemps et on en a déjà l'eau à la
bouche
voilà il regarder ces images qui nous
proviennent du groupe la dépêche en
occitanie
après sept mois de voyage dans l'espace
le rover persévérance a atterri sur mars
jeudi 18 février dernier
sept minutes de stress pour les
ingénieurs toulousain du cnes qui ont
travaillé sur le robot parmi eux
l'astrophysicien sylvestre maurice nous
décrypte la mission de persévérance sur
la planète rouge
il a été interviewé par agnès grimaldi
pour nos partenaires sur place de la
dépêche à 12
le but ultime de la mission persévérance
c'est de collecter sur mars pour la
première fois des échantillons dans des
petites éprouvette voilà exactement ses
éprouvettes à l'intérieur de laquelle
nous aurons pour chaque l'éprouvette une
quinzaine de grammes de marsura 30
éprouvette moins d'un kilo à rapporter
sur terre d'ici 2031
vous avez vu ces images spectaculaires
dans l'énoncé des titres tout à l'heure
en début de journal avec les remontées
mécaniques à l'arrêt le fath bike c'est
un vélo à assistance électrique trace sa
route sur la neige
une nouvelle activité sportifs et de
loisirs
lancé par laurent k o accompagnateur en
montagne que l'on peut découvrir à la
station de gérardmer c'est marie
danielle rogowicz et hélène le plat pour
vyas vosges qui ont testé ce nouveau
fight bike
regardez là on a un beau vélo bien
musculaire nous ce qu'on veut c'est le
mettre en mode mobile est pour ça on a
un petit capteur sur la gauche
donc on essaye d'anticiper dès qu'on
voit que ça monte un petit peu
on utilise on clique un petit mec ne
pousse comme ça ça mettra une vitesse de
plus en plus facile
c'est le dernier né dont la famille les
vélos et avec les remontées mécaniques à
l'arrêt le fan bike assistance
électrique avec ses pneus énorme va sans
peine tracer sa route sur la neige
il a fait son arrivée dans les vosges et
on peut le découvrir à la station de
gérardmer existe aussi sur le sable les
fat c'est des gros pneus surdimensionnés
avec une basse pression donc un peu
moins c'est pas des pneus gonflés à bloc
surtout pas et puis ça permet d'avoir
une bonne stabilité
le fath bike c'est encore un peu de
sport mais surtout beaucoup de plaisir
et l'assistance électrique est une aide
précieuse
ben il faut le temps d'adaptation mais
non franchement ça elle se fait
facilement
on est bien stable avec les pneus c'est
sympa ça freine bien et ça montre super
bien aussi l'assistance électrique
fonctionne très bien
le massif se prête bien à cette
discipline avec ses pentes douces certes
plus facile à pratiquer sur une neige
compacte que dans la poudreuse alors
laurent et son équipe proposent des
circuits sur des pistes damées
ça reste du vélo électrique il faut
quand même avoir un minimum de condition
physique
vous avez bien vu on fait quand même un
peu de montées au départ apprenez sur un
petit plateau et ensuite on finit par
une petite descente sur les pistes de
ski et ce 4 4 des vélos est à l'aise
partout et par tous les temps alors il a
de beaux jours devant lui là ya de la
neige qui en avait pas on pourrait quand
même faire l'activité proposer une
alternative pour les vacanciers qui
viennent à gérardmer où dans les hautes
vosges et pour son premier hiver dans
les vosges ils sont nombreux à vouloir
l'essayer le fath bac électrique sur
neige marquera si sûr de son empreinte
ces vacances de février
nous allons prendre la direction de la
chapelle du genêt dans le maine-et-loire
maintenant pour nous pencher sur un
livre baptisé regard
cet ouvrage regroupe plusieurs dizaines
de témoignages de familles touchées par
le cancer pédiatrique et cette famille
la famille a de beaux nous a reçu chez
elle avec sa fille anne laure
aujourd'hui heureusement en rémission
c'est un reportage qui est signée de
frédéric lamy pour tlc à chaud les
regarder et si le fait d'écrire un livre
au sujet de la maladie de votre enfant
vous permettait d'exorciser en quelque
sorte c'est douloureux
ve la question se pose elle s'est posée
du moins pour emmanuel de bauw qui a
vécu une leucémie à travers les yeux de
sa fille à peine âgée de 14 ans à
l'époque des faits cette maman de trois
enfants n'était pas destinée à prendre
sa plume
mais le destin en a décidé autrement
l'idée de ce livre
elle est venue d'un papa qui habite dans
l'oise qui est journaliste qui s'appelle
laurent lalo avec qui j'étais en
contacts sur les réseaux sociaux parce
que ce pape a eu un fils qui a eu une
leucémie et il a lancé l'idée l'été
dernier de faire un livre collaboratif
sur les cancers pédiatriques
c'est comme ça qu'est venue l'idée du
livre et la rédaction du chapitre que
j'ai consacré ma fille 34 familles au
total se sont retroussé les manches et
ont endossé le rôle d'auteur pour la
bonne cause
l'idée était d'évoquer la maladie sans
tabou et le combat qu'elle représente
pour lançons la famille et l'entourage
alors le chapitre consacré à nord a pris
pour base des écrits que j'avais déjà
fait j'avais créé une page facebook
privé pour nos proches rouge donné des
nouvelles où je donnais mon ressenti et
donc ça m'a paru tout naturel de
reprendre sa comme base et de décrire
comment j'avais ressenti ces deux années
de traitements lourds qu'avait subie
anne-laure pour sa leucémie
une dizaine de pages relate le combat
d'alors dont le 17ème anniversaire aura
lieu le 2 mars prochain
aujourd'hui en rémission cette jeune
femme que l'on pourrait qualifier
aisément de guerrières ou de combattante
garde paradoxalement une image légère de
sa maladie moi j'ai bien vécu un rêve
pour moi ça s'est très bien passé parce
que j'ai quand même vécu des bons
moments en même temps avec d'autres
personnes qui étaient dans le même état
tu mens oui j'étais optimiste je me
disais que c'est comme ça qu on peut
rien y faire on ne peut pas changer le
destin
autant profiter de chaque instant en
tant que comme ça quoi profiter de
chaque instant relativiser les petits
soucis du quotidien et mais plus que se
battre
nous avons finalement tous beaucoup à
apprendre de la philosophie
de ses enfants ayant vécu une maladie
grave anne laure elle a repris le cours
de sa vie
elle attend maintenant de découvrir les
différents témoignages qui composeront
le livre et puis regardez ces images qui
nous proviennent de la côte d'azur avec
le 5 km hercules liste du monaco run qui
a eu lieu dimanche dernier il a été
remporté par joshua chez peggy chez les
hommes et béatrice chaque co échec chez
les femmes la kényanne signe par la même
occasion un record du monde
ce sont des images des milles et
rousseau et d'alexandra marangoni pour
monaco info
voilà il peut regarder ces images qui
nous proviennent de martinique la baie
de fort de france va accueillir donc la
15e transat jacques vabre sur la route
du café la course à la voile
transatlantique a choisi la martinique
pour la première fois de son histoire
cette transat est suivie chaque année
par 830 mille spectateurs
après le brésil le costa rica la
colombie cette transatlantique arrive
pour la première fois aux antilles
toujours sur cette route du café
l'annoncent à d'ailleurs été faite lors
d'une conférence de presse imite année
au havre et à fort de france
cette transat prendra son départ au
havre le 7 novembre prochain
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette édition
du grand jt des territoires sur vos
chaînes régionales et locales de la tnt
et sur tv5 monde
on se retrouve pour une prochaine
édition bon courage à tous
[Musique]